[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir julien merci d'être à la
première de bain de minuit est ce que tu
sais pas sur quelle chaîne s'est dûment
pas absolument enfin on est sur la
cinquième chaîne et beaucoup de chaînes
on a trop y en a trop on trouve moi je
suis perdu va t il ya plus des missions
que deux chanteurs le oui et puis les
stars c'est vous c'est bien connu
maintenant c'est plus crédible et stable
alors on s'est connus aux bains douches
sur un ouais ça va pas mal et c'est ça
le truc
[Rires]
alors on se connaît aux bains douches à
jets pour ça que j'ai voulu que tu
fasses la première émission est ce que
tu sais que le 14 septembre c'est
l'enregistrement de la première de ban
minuit mais c'est aussi une date
extrêmement importante est ce que tu
t'en souviens un petit village en corse
une certaine virginie couperie tient
souffle déjà sur wii 2 3 je suis café
comme cadeau pour son mariage il ya deux
ans l'attend le fonds directs alors
bah il peut te laisser le micro à la fin
de l'émission fait non je pense qu'il
faudrait quelque chose
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il est toujours aussi gentil
il ya deux ans il vient aux gains de
plus souvent avec toi le plus souvent
tout seul avec moi c'est bien sans moi
alors julien tu donnes ton avis sur
beaucoup de choses là en tarente à vue à
7 sur 7 a fait une chanson sur la peine
de mort et puis beaucoup de beaucoup de
chanteurs s'exprime sur les tas de
sujets et notre ami finkielkraut et
notre ami bernard henri lévy ont fait
tout un débat pour dire que maintenant
c'est un peu dommage quand même ce soit
les les chanteurs qui parlait plus les
philosophes alors qu'est ce que tu en
penses toi moi je suis un peu de leur
avis c'est un peu de leur avis oui mais
ça n'empêche pas de donner ton avis
quand même sur ce on nous le demande
alors je te demande ton avis sur ce qui
se passe en nouvelle calédonie par
exemple pas vraiment d'avis espace donné
pourquoi passe pas je n'ai pas la
solution du problème d'avoir un mauvais
accueil denis tu penses pas que le sens
de l'histoire c'est quand même de la
nouvelle qu'a dit soit indépendante un
jour ou l'autre je pense que il ya eu
des écrits là dessus quand on dit des
choses beaucoup mieux que moi et le pen
qui dit que les chambres à gaz c'est pas
important tu en penses quoi ça vous
devriez poser la question tout à l'heure
à ma prochaine invitée qui est une
excellente réponse j'ai pas la lui
prendre parce que si jamais vous l'avez
poser encore qu'il sera prêt il fera
sûrement à sa vie vous en trouver une
autre
enfin c'est tellement indécent que j'ai
pas la vie vous donnez là dessus c'est
indécent tu donnes pas ton avis sur les
sur les faits de société cette année
c'est pas ça enfin je tiens après après
un jugement paraît trop indécent gpad
aviez la révolte g20 met à me révolter
tu veux qu'on parle du rex à leurs jours
en passant en passant c'est qu'en fait
comme chez drucker alors c'est quand le
reste c'est en janvier de 12 ans le 12
janvier pour combien de temps
pour un mois et demi un mois et demi et
pourquoi tu as choisi le rex ça change
de bercy quand tu sais que la nuit il ya
des gens formidables pulsé parce que tu
sois pas mal la nuit qu'elle est
photographe qui font des photos alors
nous à demi nue aux nanas qui s'appelle
sylvain bergère qui a fait d'eux des
reportages pour nous toutes les semaines
et on va voir le premier reportage sur
notre machine elle te plaît notre
machine je la mènerai non ta salle de
bal en machine
non je la mettrais en parlant des salles
de bains a été fait par un artiste qui
s'appelle plus généraux sur ce sera bien
je ne mettrai pas ma salle de bains
malheur c'est que ma femme les secrets
de la alors on va regarder le reportage
dé 6,1 bergère
désormais ici chaque semaine vous
retrouverez album les photos les plus
folles des plus belles fêtes de paris et
pour commencer les soirées de l'été par
sylvain bergère
[Musique]
et
ce soir-là aubin il n'y avait pas robert
de niro il était venu le samedi d'avant
ni mick jagger ce sera la semaine
prochaine mais le président de
l'assemblée nationale jacques chaban
delmas
ans
les fabricants
85 kg vont s'y glisser c'est possible il
faut garder le nom bonsoir président a
comment vas-tu qu'elle survient vu
bienvenue parmi nous merci d'être là
pour la première de balbigny j'ai pensé
que répondre à votre invitation était
une sorte d'obligation à la fois
sentimentale morale artistique
merci quand les sicav est celui ci est
que j'ai pensé qu' évidemment je ferai
un peuple à côté d'eux mais qu'après
tout comme disait libération de relance
arié libération a dit que c'était plus
fort que madonna jeu suivez mon regard
vous êtes venu comme un président mais
je suis arrivé en avion de bordeaux tout
à l'air vous atteignez avec le glam non
à vous habiller un avion du glam
oui oui j'ai eu un avion du glam d'heure
sans ça ce n'était pas possible et puis
après on n'est pas venu à pied on est
venus en voiture tout bêtement
malgré la prise d'otage vécu passé
j'étais pas dans ce coup là un bon
accord
de temps en temps en boîte non non pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout parce
que j'ai une vie réglée comme papier à
musique
le matin alain au petit déjeuner on va
porte ma feuille de route et pendant
neuf heures 10h 11h 12h jamais plus de
16 heures mais entre 9 et 16 heures j'ai
un emploi du temps minuté minutes est
minuté minutes et des jeux ou même faire
un aveu pour aller me laver les mains
disons quand le mur est ce que je veux
dire aux dix ans dans le militaire eh
ben je suis obligé de gratter sur mes
rendez vous lorsque mon horaire est
telle qu'on n'a pas prévu ça et ma vie
est ainsi depuis 40 ans moyennant quoi
je me porte bien jamais pressé j'ai tout
mon temps mais il faut vivre à la minute
elle leur faisait quand même des moments
de détente à laurent mérer le bonheur
micheline guilbeault d'air alors s'il
est venu vous aussi parce que dans
l'émission nous voulons toujours
recevoir les gens comme lorsqu'ils
sortent dans l'est dans les boîtes ou
dans les restaurants c'est à dire en
couple ça ne fait vraiment bizarre on
jamais mais ça continue est très bonne
et quand vous sortez cet ensemble
toujours justement une question qui nous
brûle les lèvres si vous êtes toujours
très amoureux chaque fois qu'on vous
voit dans des photos dans paris match en
jour de france vous donnez toujours la
main est ce que c'est pour les
photographes ou est-ce que c'est sérieux
c'est instinctif c'est instagram
c'est un réflexe naturel
regardez là non mais regardez regardez
comme elle est faite comme en volume je
ne sois pas amoureux de cette fille de
là vous allez avoir du mal ce soir
proposée est alors j'essaie alors
j'essaie de j'essayerai de faire choisir
où le relais et quand j'arrive à être
persuasif alors j'ai un petit retour moi
ce que je voudrais maintenant je sais
qu'on est dans une boîte
j'aurais quand même que vous pas que
c'est formidable et si la baisse est la
meilleure de paris ça c'est sûr j'ai
découvert ça tout à l'heure mais avec
ravissement
c'est la meilleure de paris c'est du
très bon très bon goût c'est très bien
organisé et puis julien clerc mais dit
que c'était pas du tout drogue
maquereautage et compagnie que c'était
au contraire tout à fait ça vous a vu
vous les renseignements généraux vous en
donner de bons enseignements avez vous
savez que les renseignements généraux ce
soir on fait passer une fiche entre
l'avion la voiture est ici sur les bains
attention à il paraît que le président
aulas va être là ce soir sur notre
essair attention alors j'en ai vu d'eau
on n'a pas hésité une grande fête ici
aux bains douches si j'avais si j'avais
l'occasion de faire une grande fête de
la fac mais fait ce n'est pas du tout
dit long sur mon parcours
raison de plus pour être passionné par
ce que je vois ce soir enchantée je
regarde de tous mes yeux je m'informe je
me documente me retenir des regards des
visages des silhouettes superbe risque
colosse et me dire voilà des gens qui
passent leur ennui comme ça agréablement
moi je passe mes journées à travailler
très agréablement aussi ai adoré ma
femme
par conséquent ce sont des vies
différentes nous sommes d'espèces
différentes mais cessons les espèces
différentes qui font les peuples et
grands peuvent voyez ce que je veux dire
à résidence est ce que je peux vous
demander quelque chose un tout petit peu
plus sérieux à parce que nous avons
beaucoup de téléspectateurs plus sérieux
c'est du sérieux
ce que je dis même si je le dit en
rigolant vous relirez le texte ça veut
dire quelque chose
modeste même pas modeste alors le 16
septembre
c'est l'anniversaire de votre discours
sur la nouvelle société c'était quand
même
un événement écoutez il ya trois jours
s'est accélérée vous parliez de ça il ya
trois jours
j'ai relu attentivement ce discours j'ai
découvert que sur les 47 pages à peu
près de ce discours était le discours du
premier ministre proposant la nouvelle
société à la france donc une société
plus responsable plus juste et plus
humaine en régime et j'ai constaté que
plus de 33 prendre quatre pages étaient
encore d'une actualité complète maui et
que je pourrait demain venir lire le
discours est sans vie nationale b 33 pas
sans que personne ne moufte
mais c'est vrai que tu avais oublié de
le montrer au président conflit nous
avant de le lire à la siffler c'est vrai
un peu gaffe ça quand même
oui oui oui mais c'était une gaffe je
dirais de de bonne foi
lorsque j'ai été dressé à la guerre dans
le sport j'ai été dressés à faire équipe
et a joué pour l'équipe d être
extraordinairement pour le patron pour
le chef pour le capitaine pour le
président et il ne venait pas une
seconde à l'esprit de pouvoir ni le
trahir ni même de causer le moindre tort
et comme on l'était sur discours très
pris par le discours j'ai commis
l'erreur de ne pas vérifier au moins
qu'on l'avait envoyé un d'accord et
alors vers une heure de l'après midi il
y avait un coup de téléphone de l'église
dix ans à mon cabinet dites moi le fait
un discours
4 heures frédéric préférait ne pas le
connaître par la presse alors on s'est
précipité on a envoyé des motards si on
avait pu l'envoyer à l'hélicoptère ont
leurs effets de ces données est
clairement c'était un peu tard
mais entre nous qu'il n'y avait pas eu à
côté de pompidou des gens pour mettre de
l'huile sur le feu ça n'aurait pas eu
d'effet vous êtes quand même le seul
gaulliste qui a comprimé 68 finalement
non est-ce que vous pensez que si vous
étiez resté aux affaires 4 les
soubresauts de 80 aurait pu être évité
ça je ne sais pas je ne sais pas et je
ne veux pas m'accorder des vertus que je
ne me reconnais pas moi même alors
prévenant 74 vouliez devenir président
la république en 86 vous étiez prêt à
devenir premier ministre
oui alors vous auriez fait mieux que
veulent agir l'espagne obtient le sujet
je n'en sais rien j'aurais fait
différemment
bon j'aurais fait différemment c'est à
dire aussi que j'avais proposé à la
france et aux français un grand dessein
voilà et je crois pas qu'on puisse se
passer d'un grand dessein si on veut
l'en relevé le regard des français
relance et l'espérance est réellement
que ce pays se hisse au dessus de lui
même or c'est nécessaire pour ce pays et
j'espère que le prochain président de la
république tel qu'il soit aura
conscience de cette nécessité d'un grand
dessein et qu'il aura lui le dessin par
exemple d'une nouvelle nouvelle société
car tout reste à faire et je pense que
c'est la bonne voie alors moi je ne suis
pas candidat cette fois ci parce que
comme l'avait prévu le général de gaulle
c'est plutôt trop plein je laisse passer
matin je laisse passer à tous
il va vous faire vous allez faire la
campagne de jacques chirac quand même à
moi au premier tour je le pire est
certainement jacques chirac je suis
membre du rpr il est président du rpr et
vous savez dans la vie il faut toujours
jouer
loyal 1 mais quand vous dites on dit
toujours que enfin vous dites que vous
êtes sous-employés un chat bon bien
employé ça serait quoi finalement
au mans j'ai toujours pensé quand il
était mon meilleur emploi c'était la
présidence de la république parce que je
crois que je vais faire ça nous laisse
passer en cabaret vite il se passer ce
tour-là est ce que vous connaissez la
cicciolina président eh bien j'en ai
aperçu une photographie une fois il
paraît que c'est une jolie personne elle
est très jolie
j'allais le l'interviewer as roma et
vous en êtes revenu et j'en suis revenu
à peu près à peu près sain et on va vous
montrer sur notre moniteur et passionné
sial on va vous montrer leurs proches et
la chine
teach all-in avec le lac sort c'est une
mais
tito line collison les personnalités
célèbres comiques williams est restée
phare de la mort mittal en titre lino
mitterrand lui a fait manquer un petit
lino socialiste
chirac non constitutives d'un chirac ne
lui paraît pas devoir encore que nos
chers reagan non corrigan dans
l'appareil la moelle golijov go le
passionnait sympatico un acquis sa force
commune et non comme comme elin a
captivé 1 à comines kadhafi gueddafi et
un colonel et son encontre et colonel
pinochet drive qui si le fallait pour
que telle quelle la personne est
imminente et de sécurité qui s'annonce
hors d'europe en salle qui sort d'hitler
non là où tu sais ton nom c'est une
guerre non là c'est un col en fausse et
c'est le souligner la reggina elisabeth
la segunda b non non non nous sommes et
qui ça c'est la mano l'amour est alors
assez celi piatti à la nature à la
mollesse et lady des noms
belcaid jack ou pato constitue l'hymne
marit stefania 10 monaco stéphane hains
motos modernes et matt holliday inn
ipodah celui-ci caroline de monaco
caroline à son encontre odile et la
famille mort aussi morose yes to paint
it we know jack dorsey droite
berlusconi un kitsch lynn berlusconi
white birch il envoyait minto des lames
et mais est aussi stupide
tous les matins il nous guérit tous les
dix colite si la démocratie quoi les
probablement que tous n'ont cei ou
natale padel capa djb maquis ça c'est
une sono une fête de noces en italie
appel déstabilisèrent elle aux stats et
aliens qui sont pour les pros a
brillamment que tu n'essayes roanne ce
soir elle fait cela d'elle qu'elle
éprouve à a bien manqué tout non c'est
'qui père procureur est la it à tout et
l'italian et b&you dit koke viste
qu'elle ait n'assistait pas au match et
tutti quanti sentrigo doute que
lieberman petit chollima toi midget au
parquet où nous sommes nous dans soul à
croce que probablement que toulouse
seysses à tana sano catolica qui à celui
dont la bia
qu'est ce qui te la péter non le cercle
tout le sign on non personne ne sert
personne commence à faire face à des
sommets internationaux ses allées to be
story sont à mal par laurie les soit mal
à visualiser un malade et des commerces
qui aime et qu'on aime a annoncé antoine
ancien cadre hockey novice d'apéro
procédé lequel l'office du tourisme
télévision et sur certaines portions
ok c est la comtesse askar sa kerala
membres de l'union liona total m6 qui a
poussé dans la gioconda de 6,6 à quoi à
kuan à quoi les états wagner et d'yves
notre sort dont on est wagner du
beethoven et beethoven 15,6 des trains
sinon à quoi les étals a fait mine de
serpenter à la talent il aura picoler
non non
novak a utilisé ses fans maintenant si
c'est un cas si elle avait la rive
allemande
wen louis majesty of the map et s'était
dit qu'on pourrait tout ancien hockey
gwendoline asisté à 9h solide il taira
sous commande des rues golfeur n'a ni
par écrit en 1942 à saïda sassi trop bas
la repubblica démocratique à lucile
daria mais pas les cadets se débine pas
trop mal
qui est inscrite la bière mais cela a
été vice tories sont a mal au départ
l'aurait mis six ans pour qui ce matin
pour faire de la télévision nbc et la
constance haskell à la menthe
il en a vu d'avion qui a causé par la
gioconda et de 10,6 à quoi les états
wagner les divinités sordo mannone la
ville et maintenir la bmd sinon à quoi
le et à la féminité repenti à lacanau
ils ont alors piccoli voilà alors je
voulais vous montrer ce reportage à tous
les trois c'est intéressant parce qu'on
voit donc cette fille qui finalement
était la fille d'un
d'un employé du ministère de l'intérieur
à budapest qui est passé très rapidement
en italie à travers un mariage blanc et
qui finalement participent peau enfin au
moins pour moi à une entreprise de
déstabilisation en attaquant la famille
en prêchant le désarmement en disant
qu'elle préfère faire l'amour avec
gorbatchev qu'avec reagan avec ja rule
let's kick avec pinochet et je pense et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
demandé à edouard limonov d'être là
parce que c'est edward est un russe il a
vécu aux états unis et maintenant il vit
en france où d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup
de mal à avoir un passeport j'espère que
cette émission les draps et on l'a aussi
accusé lui d'être il a eu des ennuis
avec le kgb il est désormais avec le fbi
avec la dst je dois voir avant qu'on
parle de ceux de salles sur lavaur quand
ton avis sur la question est ce que tu
penses qu'il ya 20 ans kremlin dans un
bureau gris comme ça il ya les types
qu'on dit on va faire élire une
prostituée députés pour ridiculiser la
démocratie ou est-ce que ces
paranoïaques de penser ça ils sont pas
aussi visage je crois que tu vois pas
qui sont annoncés
il faut avoir l'esprit des textes et des
izards peut-être peut-être lesquels j'ai
bel de hongrie a plu nous livre dans
cette merde mais je crois pas que ses
sbires bien organisé nous avons moi
aussi je suis fils des d'une employée d
merci c'est que j'ai fait dans les
maquis du ministère l'intérieur
soviétique oui d'accord mais c'est une
logique plus tôt elle tombe ainsi dire
en tout genre de choses nous avons tout
de même eu des expériences précise pas
du côté des soviétiques
mais du côté des nazis et est en fait
des anglais car j'ai connu un officier
supérieur de la wehrmacht
c'était dans l'entourage de feu le titre
et que j'ai retrouvé un mois et demi
après en 9,6 anglais il avait passé
sévit en allemagne
sur ordre il avait gravi tous les
échelons de la hiérarchie militaire et
il s'est démasqué qu'une fois la guerre
terminée c'était du travail préparé 25
ans elle avance 30 ans à l'as vence et
il n'était pas le seul
ça fait partie du jeu des services
secrets tandis sont vraiment solide bien
organisée c'est un jeu normal
évidemment ça surprend elle prêche pour
le désarmement elle prêche contre la
famille beaucoup du monde d'une plante
fraîche désarmement doit aussi doit
aussi au bateau tu n'auras jamais ton
passeport non pour le comprendre les
phénomènes il faut les mettre dans le
contexte propres pour moi elle est une
des stars de cette constellation
formidable des exilés des pays de l'est
parmi qui vous pouvez trouver les
polanski
cergy kazinsky écrivain américaine
maintenant la nina guinée et pour
devenir les pornostars il faudra voir
les talents oui il faut dire c'est une
ceinture moi j'ai passé une journée avec
elle je veux dire qu'elle est très
lettré c'est une star en italie
elle passe dans la rue tout le monde lui
dit bonjour on l'appelle en aura volé
parce que c'est honorable quand on est
député
est ce que vous croyez président que en
france les défis comme sylvia bourdon ou
brigitte lahaie pourrait avoir quelque
chance de se faire élire au parlement la
chambre des députés
ça dépend du mode de scrutin s'ils
figurent sur une liste à la
proportionnelle
tout peut arriver tout peut arriver si
une formation politique la place en
situation telle tout peut arriver
c'est ce qui est arrivé d'ailleurs avec
le pen avait créé avec celsius
et si c'était acheter ta uninominal
comme mon desire à l'élection une
élection libre individuel
oui c'est pareil elle n'a aucune chance
elle n'a aucune chance certains
après-midi a pas beaucoup de monde quand
même dans l'hémicycle et on sait qu'ils
ont des petits bureaux au 101 rue de
l'université est ce que quand il n'y a
pas des 5 à 7 un peu je crois un peu non
non non vous voyez pas tranché je crois
pas alors avant de avant de passer à
l'interview jagger
je voudrais rappeler les titres des
ouvrages de monsieur limonov qui a le
le poète préfère les grands [ __ ] mais
c'est très bien je les retrouve sa forme
après cela les femmes j'ai passé les
femmes ces dernières
oui j'ai déjà publié six livres ici six
livres
oui vous êtes toujours pas naturaliser
français n'ont maintenant je suis là ça
y est ah ben ça s'arrose à moi il va
s'en passer à la fonde et moi je lui
mettrais bien décoré mais bien à la fin
juillet mais très bien bienvenue par
1000 m
je voudrais ajouter un call me souviens
de cette valeur là oui pour la france
oui c'est indiscutablement un plus c'est
justement merci madame chaban-delmas
vous vous vous connaissiez limonov
j'en avais entendu parler j'avais vu lu
des articles sur lui mais je n'ai pas
encore lu de livre ou si vous venez
faire un livre la dernière mort d'un
amour s'applique à c'est toute une
équipe une équipe alors c'est un livre
de prévention en fait contre la drogue
pour les enfants de 8 à 12 ans avant
parce que déjà les enfants de 8 à 12 ans
il faut déjà les c'est surtout que déjà
il faut que très vite un enfant centre
il est responsable de sa vie qui est
chargé de mission vis-à-vis de lui-même
et qu' il y a des choses dans sa vie
qu'il peut choisir ou ne pas choisir
votre vouloir ou ne pas vouloir baisser
de l'armée on peut le trouver au partout
parce qu'il est distribué par nintendo
va bien merci
alors il y en a qui s'est beaucoup
rangée de la drogue c'est notre ami mick
jagger
on va voir son interview qui a été
réalisé par guillaume durand du service
d'information de l'a5 et qui fait le
journal télévisé sur l'a5 à partir la
semaine prochaine est-ce qu les
répétitions pour pour la tournée
européenne se passe bien et qui
participent ou répétition et quelle sera
la composition du groupe
on verra voilà c'est pour christian way
qui jouera sur scène alors avec toi je
sais pas si ce moment je suis en train
de choisir les musiciens
j'en ai
plusieurs mai
je suis parfaitement le nom je suis en
train de le première semaine de
répétitions alors moi j'essaye beaucoup
avec les défauts juste musiciens alors
en quelques semaines je vais choisir
après ça on va choisir les shows les les
chansons tout ça merde comment ça se
passe quand tu choisis des musiciens
comme ça tu tues auditionne un peu comme
pour le cinéma
oui c'est un peu le même mais la
musiciens et si vous voulez qu'on vous
faites un film ou une disent qu'il est
peut-être dans le monde entier 50
musiciens quête fantastique et après ça
vous avez plusieurs sont que très bon
oui mais le premier rang
vous avez peut-être 50 le monde alors et
je connais presque tue mais est-ce que
c'est pas difficile pour toi de dire je
préfère celui là plutôt que celui là
aussi le problème c'est pas le de façon
car simplement de jouer
c'est leur façon de vivre c'est ça c'est
dans un groupe c'est juste très bien
mais il est très difficile c'est ça
aussi il faut vivre ensemble et à la
tournée parce qu'actuellement on voit en
europe partout des tournées gigantesques
de david bowie celle de crue nourrisson
est tournée colossal des mohéliens
terrible il y aura tout le monde il a
tourné de mick jagger ce avec une
tournée style club seynois part
exactement club mais je voulais faire
quelque chose plus musical qui est assez
simple
avec deux spectacles j'aimerais les
lumières qu'on me met en europe celui de
faire quelque chose plus dans le théâtre
va jouer probablement dogo rex à paris
vous avez enregistré avec les stones
d'une vidéo aux bains douches
j'ai beaucoup aimé le vieux blues les
bus tu aimes cette ambiance club de
musiciens ouais que tu retrouves par
exemple dans les night-clubs oui j'aime
bien faire ça et il faut pas
il faut pas oublier que la musique c'est
les choses se pose le plus important
mais quand même
j'aime bien faire les choses dans les
arènes ça veut dire 18 personnes
on peut faire la lumière une station
j'aime bien les deux et j'aime bien
faire dans l'est ont été les grands
spectacles mais il faut pas oublier les
petits et il est là et la vie de mick
jagger actuellement ce public est centré
sur londres où tu continues à te partagé
entre paris par la france selon alain
comme les futures le musicien il faut
voyager pour moi la musique pour voir
les gens au pouvoir
la vie j'ai pourtant je peux pas renier
oui mais quand tu vis en france est ce
que est ce que tu écoutes par exemple de
l'artiste français vous êtes intéresse
pas trop il faut tout avoué la main or
est-ce que je peux dire la vérité il
faut dire que oui c'est pas en cours
mais non mais en france je suis je
prends mes vacances
mais alors où je suis dans le studio
d'enregistrement et je vois pas beaucoup
pas beaucoup les musiques
si je sens à paris c'est presque
toujours la musique américaine va
arriver au sujet épouvantable série
stone ce que se passe-t-il avec les
stones est ce que vous voyez souvent est
ce que vous avez à faire des tournées ou
ou pas oui je vois est si souvent je
veux lire et lacs et au roller charlie
peel héroïne et ils peuvent ils ont tous
à l'ombre et habite londres
moi je suis alors on se voit pour
quitter les agneaux
moi je crois mais
on a parlé de fer en tournée
pendant un an mais vous vous sentez
toujours très proches les uns des autres
oui mais on en a eu plein de problèmes
mais moi je ne peux pas arrêter faire ma
carrière si le
et ne sont pas ils ont pas d'accord
parce que dans la musique il faut avoir
l'harmonie et si vous n'avez pas
l'harmonie on peut passer la lumière
musique
ben moi je peux tu voudrais continuer
avec moi me dit mais je suis surtout les
autres ils sont les projets et ils ont
des projets de disent qu'ils ont des
choses pour un ange et coince ça va
continuer
[Musique]
non
deux ans
alors
[Musique]
voilà
quoi
ou pas
c'est moi
[Musique]
howe
ouah
non
tha
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
partout
dans tout
k
oui
stop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou alors dans les boîtes on se rend
compte on rencontre des gens qu'on
rencontre pas dans la même journée est
un jour tts cilaos allons y à roda qui
est arrivé à leur rodage sais pas si
vous savez qui c'est mais c'est quand
même vous avez fait vite album ensemble
dans un poème sûrement j'ai sûrement et
puis alors après on a lu dans la presse
des choses que tu as dit qu'ils étaient
pas très gentil quand même ça faisait un
peu les nôtres mais ça faisait appeler
l'aller macartney moi je dis oui c'était
un peu ça comme ça c'était très bien si
jamais ça c'est oui ouais non non et
alors il y avait un côté quand même
quand vous êtes retrouvé j'ai trouvé ça
formidable parce qu'on a tous écouté vos
disques et tout et j'ai dit faut les
réunir à la télé alors j'aimerais
maintenant je deviens un coup tous les
deux officiellement lorsque la boîte
mais aussi ceux qui croient plus tard
même mot était absolument les faits une
réunion tout métal et non pas que les
gens soient étonnés jeudi est un auteur
et un compositeur se disent beaucoup de
choses par chansons interposées
c'est un
une relation passionnelle et il est
normal que quand il y à un arrêt
provisoire ou définitif dans l'eure
dans leur travail dans l'art amour cela
comme on voudra ça ne se passe pas comme
ça bonjour bonsoir on arrête avec
ensemble en plus etienne a dit des
choses après c'est vrai président a été
du freudisme de bistrot paix tutu et le
père tout ça ce n'est pas peut-être pas
trop d'alerté il a dit beaucoup de
choses et comme dans les paroles de
chansons il y avait des choses bien et
des choses moins bien des des choses
réussies et des choses par ici moi j'ai
rarement ou jamais répondu parce que moi
je suis musicien et ce n'est pas mon
rôle des cris des paroles une des choses
qui l'a dit une fois parce que à chaque
fois quand les choses étaient belles
pourquoi je souhaitais pas bay pas
répondait qu'à jeter bail est paré pour
non plus parce que je me pardonnait tout
parce que c'était joli parmi les choses
je lis qu'il ait dit il avait dit qu'il
a arrêté d'écrire pour moi parce qu'il
ne tenait pas faire le sac des petites
filles mais je pense que me laisser là
où je voulais en venir à égalité un
partout la balle au centre
non non non c'était pas beau et le jour
où tu avais dit ça dans le journal
j'ai lu des trucs quand même assez dur
c'est le dit c'est lui qui le dit en or
not to chat soit la relation
passionnelle
tout ça c'est pas grave ce qui est
important c'est que il ya des chansons
qui est tant mieux si elle reste dans le
coeur des gens ils un jour de les
retravailler tous les deux être
maintenant maintenant qu'on fait tous
les deux activités scientifiques et la
nation nous ne faisons pas nous sommes
la petite fille alors la petite fille
vanessa
comet a vendu 17 us et non je pense
qu'on doit pas ton nous
pardon mais pas trop pas loin d'un
million c'était beaucoup d'argent alors
sur ses coutures de saint lô quelqu'un
de le lire ou valeur de ce monde après
tout moi si tu peux nous chantait joe
sexy tu vas pas de chanter en espagnol
as si je chante en espagnol mais penser
ça ce soir
toi tu peux pas de chanter toi ça sera
difficile de ne pas le faire juste une
phrase hadassah je préférerais que ce
soit l excellent dans une chanson de
céline qui connaît par coeur les deux
énormes yahoo
je ne peux pas le petit jeu mais aller
chez nous quelqu'un crée maintenant je
te trouve sharon un vilain soir je ne te
ferait dans la micro ni de grands très
bien très bien
alors venez ça tu peux quand tu sais ce
que ça newcomer non non a new comers
c'est quelqu'un qui monte en toi tu es
un new comer mais comme newcomer tout le
monde emploie ce mot nous on avait
inventé un nouveau seuil wannabe because
i wanna be a star
abb wanna die main alors maintenant on
va voir une séquence qui s'appelle et
wanna be où on voit des gens qu'on juste
trente secondes pour expliquer pourquoi
ces vagues destin voilà alors on va
regarder ça il est reçu parmi les
véritables libertin que les sensations
communiqué par l'organe de louise sont
celles qui flatte davantage et dont les
impressions sur les plus vives sans
doute beaucoup de tous les écarte que
vous allez voir peindre ou déplairont
mais il s'en trouvera quelques-uns qui
vous échauffer et voilà tout ce qui je
m'appelle serpentine tessier j'ai 24 ans
je suis comédienne et je fais partie de
la compagnie patrice biget mon téléphone
43 27 91 31
bonjour je m'appelle olivier védrine
j'ai 24 ans et j'expose cette maquette
or à la cité des sciences et l'industrie
dans le cadre de l'expo eureka l'europe
c'est un projet c'est un projet grand
hôtel pour les chercheurs scientifiques
européens
c'est à la fois aussi un espace public
tout le dôme un espace privé des
cellules est un lieu un lieu d'échangé
lieu de travail quels auditorium il ya
un terrain d'accueil c'est saint séverin
en plein coeur du vieux paris de la
grisaille et ce projet rayonne entre
saint jacques et saint germain voilà 42
93 40 14
vos chapeaux 1910 un peu compliqué comme
mon nom devant rob lève c'est pas moi
qui les crée moi j'ai créé des
personnages
en fait j'adore les costumes c'est
samedi
je dirige les costumes de paris c'est
pas une mince affaire mais c'est
fascinant
c'est facilement créer des personnages
qui vont vivre pendant deux heures le
temps d'un film temps le temps d'une
fête
vous sortez là ce soir
habillée comme ça vous mais c'est faire
48 78 41 02 non les boules de cristal
c'est pas mon truc je m'appelle cyril
strauss j'ai 30 ans et c'est
l'astrologie traditionnelle qui
m'intéresse et je la pratique depuis
longtemps
alors si vous avez envie de faire un
cadeau à la star de votre coeur aller
lui chercher dans les étoiles
son thème astral sur cassette pour cela
c'est simple il suffit de me communiquer
son heure sa date et son lieu de
naissance en appelant love astral aux 45
43 31 60
bonsoir je m'appelle marque askenazy
j'ai 29 ans je suis éditeur et j'ai
cassé ma tirelire c'est pour faire un
brico abricots c'est un magazine pour
les enfants comme moi entre 18 mois et 4
ans il ya des comptes et des comptines
ya des jeux et des histoires
il ya même des conseils pour mes parents
abricot ses envies dans toute la france
chez les marchands de journaux ou par
abonnement vous m'appelez aux 40 67 96
bon ben maintenant j'aime brosser les
dents et puis je vais faire dodo
alors maintenant on va voir un clip dans
la musique était faite par julien clerc
et les paroles pas par toi c'est normal
à bord c'est la vie c'est la veillée ce
gars l'automne l'été l'hiver il ya des
trucs devant d'accord et c'est quoi le
printemps plutôt là c'est l'avis de tout
le monde
avant d'aller nous faire dire la tour
alors qu'est ce qui a fait les paroles
d'un mac ne sont pas mal les parents
voilà
tout le monde connaît virginie coupérie
c'est comme ça qu'on dit sortie en 1re
série qui peut être championne de france
bientôt
voilà je connais georges marc benamou
georges marc benamou c'est le patron de
club et franck maubert travail à globe
avant et se sont séparés et à bain de
minuit on a récupéré franck tu l'as wihr
et où il est parti de son parti de son
plein gré on pousse on regrette alors
maintenant voici denise beaulieu qui
vient de faire un scoop absolument
génial vous avez vécu dans l'intimité de
le pen pendant combien de temps une
semaine vous l'avez fait complètement
craqué parce que depuis il dit qu'il est
plein de trucs et son terrible
développement de discuter en même temps
on a fait d'une ou deux gars comme ça
faut pas lui directement mais front
national ce qui la même chose vous aviez
déjà fait très fort avec les toreros non
oui j'ai fait dix ans ex est un peu plus
loin dans les détails des moeurs à
sexuelle de ces messieurs
j'allais pas quand même approfondir la
question à cette fois l'or est allé
aussi loin qu avec les toreros n'ont
débuté il ya des choses qu'il vaut mieux
laisser dans l'ombre jusqu'à trop
horrible à l'horizon bien le journal
ça va bien ça va bien mais surtout c'est
pas c'est pas un coup funk
qu'on a fait c'est pas une imposture
comme je crois que ça fait profondément
un sens politique et que ça fait deux
ans que l'homme existe bientôt ça fait
deux ans qu'on cherchait à faire dira le
pen ce qu'ils pensent vraiment parce que
c'est pas un homme politique comme les
autres panneaux politique du tout et que
tout son jeu c'est de masquer ce qu'il
est vraiment c'est d'avoir la parra et
l'apparence la respectabilité et je
crois que tant en usant des méthodes
donnent deux docteurs wallraff
d'infiltration
on a réussi à perdre ira le pen des
choses qu'il ne dit pas tout beau
maintenant il le dit à la radio
maintenant il a débloqué rtl dimanche
dernier à la radio où il a dirigé le
monde les semaines les chambres à gaz un
point de détail je crois qu'il est
devenu fou je crois que globe a réussi à
lyon a démontré que c'est un raciste
obsessionnel un antisémite obsessionnel
est un homme profondément vulgaire pas
un homme politique respectable un homme
politique comme les autres décès c'est
ça la grande leçon est ce qu'on a voulu
démontrer et c'est ça le grand mérite de
l'article de venise et c'est notre
mission je crois que sans lui
l'air sera un peu meilleur sans les
totalitaires de toutes sortes c'était
dur d'avoir sa patte sur sa crise comme
ça on va jouer comme à mission
impossible
j'étais fervente du mr avec le choix des
ouvrages thibert vous avez eu peur des
fois quand même grave s'est secrètement
dans la cour on est d'accord pour que le
parti puisse le prendre en charge
et tout ce qui a marqué dans le journal
c'est vrai tout à fait vérifié
bravo bravo georges marc bravo denise
alors maintenant francs que tu va nous
parler de notre feuilleton qui commence
ce soir
brûlé l'évaluer les frères va du recul
qui sont deux trous de photos né au
kenya qui fait des indiens du kenya
les indiens du kenya et qui vivent à
londres sont très jeunes d'environ 23
ans et ils font des photos a eu des
ventes sont fait remarquer notamment
avec une photo de bottier pas maintenant
je fais cette affaire un peu le pendant
du globe et l'intello globe le fait et
sa mort douce et plus on va voir le
premier épisode du feuilleton des
véhicules cinq minutes par semaine
désormais dans mad men oui merci à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
alors ça fait vachement plaisir qu'un
groupe comme kid creole échos connaître
face un morceau qui s'appelle don't
think the bains douches
manque de pot maintenant ça s'appelle
les ben ouais mais est-ce que tu as
écouté les textes on a de la chance on
est là c'est carrément génial et ce
qu'ils disent
d'abord parce que d'abord lui c'est un
mec vraiment sympa extra y tourne alors
il aime la nuit aime vraiment s'éclater
s'amuser en plus de textes il très fort
il dit lorsque si un jour les russies
d'occuper l'europe comme pourrait
publier nous les amériques a donc bien
sûr de ne pas avoir la pyramide ne pas
voir le pont suspendu de savoir babylone
il s'en fout mais c'est de ne pas venir
dans ce qui leur reviendraient vraiment
c'est vraiment sympa kid creole dancing
de bains douches
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est qui le
le
[Musique]
m
l'accord
key
[Musique]
m
michelin des responsables des bains et
chaque semaine oui tu vas venir nous
présenter le chouchou de la semaine
comme à la bonne époque dorée celle ses
chouchous à la semaine
alors qu'est ce que c'est cette même
première c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas
créateur de chauffage habite à lille et
cousin de pierre d'albi ouais c'est
quelqu'un dont on parlera beaucoup en
quelques années qu avec ottawa qui a une
voix exceptionnelle c'est très chouette
pour chercher chouette qu'on pourra
comparer américain michael jackson avait
mérité obtenu l'américain il était
certes heures de la main il habite en
angleterre la britano ritter le numéro
rapaces à paris à la cigale au mois
d'octobre à des périodes où ils étaient
restreintes aujourd'hui son nom de
l'artiste bernois est parfait le
mademoiselle qu'est ce que vous faites
alors la vie dans la ville je sors un
disque
au mois d'octobre celui-ci billets qui
va s'appeler victimes d'essence
je ne suis pas d'essence la faillite de
ces super six étapes les colons et
elisabeth rose
oui par comme loana exactement j'ai
parlé du raid par an avec le pain c'est
très bien et j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
pour les paroles caroline l'abbé pierre
blier
c'est pas mal oui la boîte et pour la
musique fip fonctionne
et ben voilà on est désarmé j'espère que
ça vous plaît alors maintenant on va
voir une interview la deuxième partie de
l'interview la cicciolina alors c'est
l'interview définitive c'est l'interview
la plus hard que ça non si tout est
passé en revue la halle et sur l'île à
deux
jolina outils masturber espèce s'est
fait vivre la masturbation toutes les
espèces une farine plastique à six
personnes et la discothèque a italienne
est inquiet des sols resteront pas tout
la mort et qu'on aurait fallu
transporter des crises call home alone
zone emea chez la verdure les équipes
comme été du climat si c'est trop
violent et shaman jeune femme et ne-yo
et et les espèces au palais des geishas
et c'est nos capitaux belle balle et
dégage
no comment non tu peux l'expliquer
françoise d'avoir tous partis
préservatif beyon ancrait donald
préservatif hyper califano 7-5 6-1 en à
la sexualité à djelfa talks to be you
dicko qu'elle ait forcé nonistes est
atteinte à perros existait et non
château syrie plein d'autres rapportent
autre homme noir mais on la donne est
restée seulement les personnes et les
états unis n'entretiennent de perdre
rapport totalement mon ado par les 17
solitaires ces tueries viols nepean
celle à 16 soit l'état mais piacere
langue clitoridienne ternie par la mort
d'un jeune homme d'origine arabe à
canala c est important de porter la
mission d' adèle cesse de masculin non
importantes et avait de la consistance à
des faits l'amour est bonne et que nous
avons utilisé l'api lola
de flamme pour les spermicides maillot
dit qu il ne fait qu ils en soient
d'accord
l'une des causes de la mort et qui dit
aux gens que la pile al djabari tous nos
mails adja fatou la mort comme doit
ainsi contrainte ancien no 1 contre 6
066 si amy ps pourrait rebondir comme
bambino maïs a atteint quelques credo
kabambi né à l'état de canicule et vent
mollit néocons giocattoli également
collomb ancien nom facto la mort est
simplement wire chemical d'armes entre
façe vola mot à dire que nous handicape
atomique et célébrer la mort et telle
qu'est les personnes normales
son agonie d'un thriller qui compte
investir et la mort le drone ce soit ait
encaissé deux buts alors qu'il faut
c'est que l'on transmet soualais une
zone non tu sers moubarak est longue
hadja fatou la morricone ou la donne
s'il connaît nous selon que l'on attend
la cathédrale l'ancien camp mais c'est
la nostalgie des grandes électoraux
tombe comme une gamme que quelqu'un
colonna évolue en solo contre ia nimani
pino malfato la mode qui ça y est
vous n'aurez naturel non est trop grande
et trop petit hôtel tout seul my world
and see you soon to my world en namibie
hashimoto michel tomi bagne tôt à mieux
est ce un regret dit ah non miyamoto
fondamentale incana de requêtes sur ma
personne en moto2 chaîne moto sensu al
kindi à mladic est la sienne soit l'état
le foostie gahtane en doublettes et
qu'il a compris lire c'est le lendemain
ni intimidation autisme deauville l'ogre
australien de la photo la mort il ya une
longue épopée lychees sous la main
keenan et la guille à perte
dans toutes les émissions de télé on
voit myriam dabo dans toutes les autres
on doit des extraits de james bond
pour ban minuit philippe guérin a essayé
de trouver un james bond français vous
allez voir ce que ça donne ça commence à
lui l'idée en avant
[Musique]
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez répondu à
cette annonce et bien c'est parce que je
suis et vous que maintenant j'ai demandé
longtemps que j'ai envie de couleurs
j'ai 18 ans je voulais toujours faire ça
j'avais d'autres je fais figure en une
fois tout ça mais jamais eu de suite
et là j'ai vu une annonce j'ai dit
pourquoi est-ce qu'au premier abord vous
n'avez pas l'air d'être non mais
l'endroit du personnage de sept jours en
suisse eut au moins je me disais j'ai lu
j'ai vu les premiers james bond si si ça
m'intéresse c'est un roman policier
my name and shame on line name is bond
james bond à une main que j'ai eu six
bombes
my name s gaz band vous pouvez leur
faire elle-même gxs bombe
je suis j'ai secondes je suis juste bon
avec espionne russe à la cause mon gars
des envieux je souhaite juste de la
guerre et je cherchais quelqu'un
protégez moi je vous en prie je sais que
vous êtes revenu new york pour me sauver
protéger moi je me sens pour ichat
je vais vous demander quelques instants
et nous
mon parti compte les zones chaudes
soirées chaudes sous ainsi si oui j'ai
un roman très chaud j'avais mis le rouge
pour vous à sortir non à quoi vous êtes
sûreté à votre temps
[Musique]
moi
je suis jean bond je suis jean bond est
ce que vous seriez capable
oui de redescendre maintenant comme ça
les quatre étages avec des ficelles des
cordes oui mais mené les cordes en
rappel c'est possible ou pas bah
appartient au moment où je descends
rappelle oui pourquoi pas oui mais voilà
le problème
elle avait pas de problème il accorder
un peu quoi enfin vous êtes prêts à le
faire mais pas tout à fait
vous douté de moi oui ah bon
non
je veux être défendable
l'appel pratique propose ce pareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
alfredo j'ai voulu que tu viennes dans
la première émission de bain de minuit
parce que je suis un fanatique hawks et
depuis depuis le début depuis l'épée de
bois depuis va péronne je crois que
comédie policière a été un grand moment
à chaillot quand à wii avec le décor qui
s'ouvrait la maison qui s'ouvrait j'ai
vu luxe au palace et puis il ya dix ans
reine de coeur d'une chaîne anglaise
alors aujourd'hui il ya cette pièce de
marivaux qui est tout à fait étonnante
parce que faire jouer des gens qui sont
habillés comme c'est grotesque comme les
singeries du 18e qui joue marivaux avec
l'accent argentin
c'est quand même un pari incroyable non
il ya des gens qui vont voir ça il avait
ce jeune qui rouspètent tu sais que il
ya quelqu'un qui écrit à istres et la
culture en demandant d'interdire notre
petit espace qu'est il trouvait que ça
ait porté tort à marivan et moi je
craque et non et marivaux doit bien se
réjouir de cette version parce que là
ces pièces qui ont été créés par les
comédiens italiens soyaux des comédiens
comme nous qui parlait avec un fort
accent et il aimait sa basse qu'il
disait et il parlait le texte plus
lentement ce qui donnait aussi un champ
dans son offre à ses différents et qui
sale et des poudres est salée de coiffer
et puis parler qu'anglais toute façon on
avait une masse qu à masquer pas lui qui
rappelle les les singes et les toute
façon dans les pièces de marivaux
qu'aujourd'hui on considère les pièces
très formel très structuré prével d'un
point de vue psychologique quand même
avec un pc des pirouettes
alors si tu crois que c'est sans
j'apporte l'animalité la force
nécessaire à ce texte et que parfois ce
sont un peu endormi précieux appelé à
brûler sa poudre et mais c'était de
texter hyndman et au corps et elle dit
c'est chaud et line naturellement gelé
comme si vous ne lui donnez
sans donner de l'importance avec une
force naturelle expliquer ces animaux
par le sort des mages il donne cette
force au texte et sa régie a beaucoup de
spectateurs il ya ceux qui trouvent ça
peut-être mais c'est bien cette nuit tu
trouvais ça formidable
oui aujourd'hui un excellent c'est la
générale aujourd'hui oui oui ça s'est
passé formidablement bien
et puis tu sais que c'était la pièce que
avec laquelle moi j'ai fait mon absence
voilà moi à cause de toi ou grâce à toi
plutôt j'ai eu envie d'aller en
argentine alors raconte-moi le voyage
comment ça s'est passé parce que vingt
ans que tout est parti de wade génocide
c'est à dire que pour moi c'était assez
particulier puisque et en même temps on
a fait un film a été la libération alors
à la fois cette réalité et fiction
mélanger c'est une fiction qui m'a
permis en même temps de découvrir toute
une partie de mon pays que j'ai
t'aiderai je n'aurais pas osé toucher
107 caméra derrière moi alors il ya eu
des choses drôles de choses mandole des
choses fortes mais évidemment pour moi
j'ai passé déjà les mêmes tant de vies
ici que là-bas
l'argentine vit un peu aujourd'hui et
qui sont passés derrière elle avec son
sens sa grande époque derrière elle
alors avant de regarder le sujet extrait
du film que tu as fait avec jean-pierre
thibaudat a été la libération pour la
set où il joue
je voudrais justement de poser cette
question est ce qu'aujourd'hui tu vas
pas le sentiment qu'avec l'arrivée d'un
pouvoir politique disons équilibré avec
alphonsine et le changement de capital
est ce que tu crois pas que l'argentine
est en train de de partir finalement
dans une nouvelle direction est ce que
le changement le fait que vielles demain
carmen de patagones ya devienne une
nouvelle capitale pour l'argentine que
l'argentine se décide à conquérir le le
le sud est ce que c'est pas finalement
un nouveau départ ou est ce que toi
c'est ton triste finalement non c'était
le problème maintenant c'est qu'on les
voit le mal d'alcool chine vient d'être
touchée il ya eu les élections
législatives comme tu le sais elle est
péronisme arrêt pl est une peinture
moi ce qui me semblait logique puisque
c'est une force très importante du pays
et mais il faudrait comme peut-être ici
aussi que ceux des forces s'est mis
ensemble travailler pour les pays les
envols en profondeur ce qui était un
pays qui était non pas à ruiner c'est un
pays qui a souffert une très grand
mystère dans les dernières années et je
crois qu'il sait qu'il peut repartir le
pays je ne sais pas si tout de suite
mais ce soir voilà soir
alors on va regarder le sujet de ernesto
sabato lundi que le grand écrivain qui
va nous parler du tango
merci alfred la ville merci j'ai à
l'essai qui s'appelle la métaphysique
qui pango qui analyse justement ce
problème les paroles de peut-être comme
si ces deux endroits en france
les tangos le plus important les paroles
des tangos ce qui est important ce sont
posés toujours le problème métaphysique
la mort la solitude
je ne sais pas comme si bien en france
je pense qu'il n'y a pas un bon dessin
coin mais en contre vous c'est pas comme
ça quand on ne veut pas se rencontrer
comme normalement il
c'était comme se tenait frustation le
ratage ratage compte quand on doit ces
rencontres ne se rencontrent pas comment
tu te dis qu'ils encaissent ainsi dans
un cri désespéré de la vie où tout est
tout a raté tout arrêter tout ça tout ça
c'est typique des grands pittoresque
stoupy dont je parle des grandes
créations
il ya des poètes de la rue je les gagne
par exemple dit c'est pour les postes
des problèmes existentialiste webb ellis
épaule était une espèce existentialiste
avant la lettre au même ordre la lettre
alors et tango peiné de resservir une
espèce il ya les sens métaphysique gamme
sens métaphysique
elle enseigne également à l'heure même
la musique c'est assez triste n'est ce
pas mélancolique quelquefois tragique
c'est toujours la frustration
toujours l'on parle de l'amour de la vie
qui s'en va il ne retourne pas de l'être
la bid line aubry consist orgie
et histoire parce que j'avais chantier
un jaune d'oeuf 1 go
voyez maintenant faire quelques uns
ok
[Musique]
m
ségo et savent
c'est moi j'ai atteint ma cigarette
quand même
[Musique]
mon affiche merci
alors
on a derrière nous
le groupe lui ce rizzo trio
louis triaud trio c'est lui au milieu là
les fabuleux avec victorio portilla
vittorio pour rien wright guerdat kewell
ainsi que
daniel cabreira à droite
[Musique]
à
où
vous
[Musique]
nous
tu vois je suis planté
mentez
m
bombay
les enfants astronomes
bon
car
voir s'envoler
au millionnaire ce plan
tu vois je suis planté
t
encore deux points de la ville
mes yeux fardés
de cet estuaire
on vient
mais trois les
bonnet
un long baiser salé
[Musique]
c'est devant qu'il me
et qui veut dire
et dans ce monde où tous les hommes se
croient debout
seul à me vanter me traîner
genou
l'eau
non
seulement qui le mena
mais qui veut dire fou
et dans ce monde
tous les ans croit debout je suis le
seul à me vanter
[Musique]
l'année
à genoux
tu vois je suis planté
[Musique]
dans un ciel de l'église j'ai jeûné
g
croix dessus
que je viens
le sommet
mais qui
fond du ciel
toi de ton
m
tu vois je suis planté
sur le d
[Musique]
poitiers
ici
clignote s'en aille
[Musique]
ou bien
non
oh
en
ce
plus maintenant
il veut du rock
et dans ce monde tous les ans ce droit
debout
sur le seul à me prendre et les genoux
plus
donc il me donne
le dira
dans ce monde
sans ce droit demont
je sors en novembre
allez
des genoux
tu vois supplanter
l'antenne
planté
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux